[Music]
when you look at the Earth from space
you don't see the 241 countries and
territories that we've divided ourselves
into you don't see the boundaries that
we've carved out through bloodshed or
the conflicting ideologies that have
evolved on either side of them you just
see one giant rock home to a species
that has the capability to tear itself
apart after World War Two where humans
wiped out 3% of the world's population
global leaders began discussing the idea
of having one-world government to avoid
repeating the mistakes made over the
previous 25 years the idea quickly
fizzled out but they might have been
onto something what problems could
having a single government solve for us
who would be put in charge and how could
it all go terribly wrong this is what if
and here's what would happen if the
world was a single country for centuries
leaders have fantasized about a day when
World Peace becomes a reality but as
long as countries are blowing each other
up over political and religious
differences that doesn't seem very
likely so what if we just took all the
countries in the world and merged them
into one giant nation surely there'd be
nothing to fight about anymore right
Ian wouldn't be that simple it's not
like we'd be starting from scratch
instead we'd be taking thousands of
years of cultural histories prejudices
languages and currencies and
amalgamating them into one giant melting
pot it would be one of the most
complicated endeavors the human race has
ever undertaken so before we go any
further
maybe we should weigh out the pros and
cons and ask ourselves would it really
be worth it
starting on the bright side the first
pro of making the world a single country
would be that we could tackle the
Earth's problems as a unified force one
area where we'd see this benefit most is
in our planets fight against climate
change for example in 2015
both the United States and China pledged
to drastically cut their greenhouse gas
emissions as part of the Paris climate
agreement since then China has heavily
invested in clean energy sources to keep
up with their goals while the United
States has all but pulled out of their
commitment a world government would
eliminate this sort of inconsistency by
allowing us to develop a global plan of
attack on how to make improvements to
our environmental situation and by
ensuring that it would be followed
across the board this unified front
would also come in handy in times of
crisis such as natural disasters or
disease epidemics these catastrophes
wouldn't have to impact developing
nations so much harder than developed
ones resources could be spread out to
make sure every part of the world have
the same opportunities to recover the
next great benefit would be that acts of
war could be eliminated because the
primary reasons for Wars being started
in the first place would be almost
non-existent some experts think that the
elimination of war is an absolute
necessity of humankind wants to survive
it's estimated that there are 17,000
nuclear weapons on the planet right now
with France China the US Russia Pakistan
Israel India the UK North Korea all
possessing them if nuclear weapons were
to be used again we'd all suffer no
matter where the conflict was taking
place the third good thing that would
come from a one-world government is that
there'd be a better balance of quality
of life across the globe for starters
with no more Wars defense budgets would
be dropped substantially making more
cash available for other needs like
global healthcare
with everyone reporting to the same
governing party and following the same
rules it would be easier to defend human
rights and set safe labor standards for
workers in every part of the world a
global nation would mean a global
currency which would mean a reduction of
the economic power of developed
countries like China with no currency
exchange in the mix China would no
longer have the means or the need to
offer up goods and services on the world
market on the cheap eliminating this
means giving companies a fair shake no
matter where they might be in the world
developing countries could benefit
although it wouldn't just happen
overnight now a global government
wouldn't guarantee that everything on
the planet would all be sunshine and
roses and that brings us to the cogs our
first and potentially most important con
is that the wrong person could be put in
charge of the entire planet to elect
them there would probably need to be one
vote from every former country but
campaigning for the position might still
be similar to what we see in today's
elections obviously there can be
problems and you can never rule out the
possibility of corruption or backroom
dealings who's to say we wouldn't end up
with a leader with malicious interests
in mind one of the foundations of the
Nazi political belief system was the
establishment of a global government
which in their case would have led to
more genocide and the wiping out of
democracies around the world in order to
force their political ideology onto the
masses our second problem would be that
the idea of nationalism would be lost
nationalism develops cultures and it
helps fuel a want and a need to achieve
things like technological advancements
think about the space race between the
US and Russia and the way it affected
the global desire to explore space not
to mention bragging rights when it comes
to kicking some butt at sporting
competitions but now that we think of it
no nationalism could lead to some good
stuff - no nationalism can mean people
are far less concerned about where a
person is from and more accepting of
cultural and religious
differences which means less potential
for conflict so maybe we're best to move
on from this one
our final con is that the whole thing
would be extremely complicated and could
just end up leading to more global
conflict making the world a single
country would be a logistical nightmare
we'd all have to adapt to whatever
Universal languages we decide to use and
then there'd be the potentially bigger
issue of figuring out a common currency
how long would exist in currencies be
accepted
what can we develop to oversee the
physical printing and distribution of
new money so many moving parts
on top of that there's the fact that
there will still be a good chunk of the
world population who are opposed to the
whole idea of a single world government
sure we'd all be living under one
umbrella but it could be an umbrella
full of rebellions widespread corruption
and cultural clashes the very kinds of
conflict we were trying to avoid in the
first place it sounds like a good idea
on paper but considering how unbalanced
the current political and economic
fields are it would take a lot of
convincing to get every country on board
maybe it would take world war 3 in order
to convince everyone and by then it
might be too late but that's a topic for
another what-if
[Music]